هذه 100 يوم 100 يوم اصعب 100 يوم في
حياتنا شفناها مكف شرد والخوف عمر ما شفنا
الخوف في حياتنا اي الخوف الحين والبرد
والسقعه والجوع وخليك فقدنا ز احبابنا
واولادنا الان وبعد مرور 100 يوم على
الحرب نحن نتنفس لا هذه ليست حياه نحن
نتنفس فقط اعتبر نفسنا احياء تقطيع تشريد
حرمان سماع الاهل لا امان حتى واحنا بنام
في مراكز اللجوء في المدارس فيش
امان طبعا على غرار روايه 100 عام من
العزله احنا عشنا 100 يوم في الحرب على
قطاع غزه مرت علينا وكانها 100 عام ان لم
يكن اكثر كل شيء في حياتنا تغير كل ملامح
الحياه واصدقائنا وفي المحيط اللي حوالينا
تغيرت علينا سواء بالبدايه من نزوح الى
نزوح سواء من فقدان الزملاء والاصدقاء
صواريخ براميل متفجره بيوت ضعيفه في خيام
100 يوم الحرب يعني قول اكثر من نص مليون
دقيقه خوف ضمار رعب الم هذه الكلمات رغم
شموليتها لا تكفي ولا تعبر عما يعانيه
الشعب في
غزه فيما يوم الحرب هدول فقدت طبعا اللي
هو والده اثناء مرور طبعا من حاجز الامان
وبعديها صرت اسمع طبعا على الاخبار انه
جارنا او اعمامنا طبعا وا ابن خالتي
طبعا اه والله 100 يوم من الحرب كانت
قاسيه بكل معنى الكلمه انا ربما كان
اقساها اعتقالي 33 يوم من قبل جيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وتغيبي عن اسرتي
وعائلتي ووالدي ووالدتي واطفالي
وزوجتي 100
يوم من ال يوم كان يمكن ان تقتل وتصبح ر
شهيدا او تصبح رقما من الضحايا
او تصاب باصابه خطيره او غير ذلك احنا
بدنا نعيش يا
الله
تحتال شم ايمن محمد حمدان ابو حطب مغسل في
مستشفى ابو يوسف النجار مر علينا 100 يوم
يعني ما خلينا ولا حاجه مسعفين اشتغلنا
معهم دكاتره صحفيه كل حاجه والحمد لله
يعني شفنا اشلاء وكثير في في بكل الحروب
ما شفناش اكثر من هيك فرقت اصحابي اخواني
اولاد عمي اولاد خالتي ما كله ماخليت اعز
اصحاب عندي
فرقتهم صنا 100 يوم مهجرين تهجرنا من غزه
ل خانون من خونس للمغازي تبهدلنا كثير سقع
وتلوث كثير وابني كثير مريض وجينا من
المغاز لرفح برضه في خيم برضه مزعين وبرد
وسقعه للاطفال
يعني وعننا الاولاد استشهدوا مش واحد عن
والله فوق ال 40 شهيد والحاره كلها دمار
ودمروا الدور حرقوا الدنيا وهان قاعدين
هنا في الخيام فقدنا ناس غاليين وعزيزين
علينا واخوتنا راحوا واهالينا راحوا ايش
ضل و دورنا راحت ايش ظل ظل شي حلو في
الحياه ما ضل
شي يجب ان يعطى الناس امل في غد افضل
الناس الان اصبحت غير قادره على مجرد
الحلم بغد
افضل